what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to geek culture explained
and in the most recent episode of
she-hulk basically as usual nothing
happened but we did get the introduction
of mr immortal so that's cool so here's
the question we're gonna answer in this
video who is mr immortal because i
imagine a lot of you all are probably
wondering that so as you can figure out
from the tv show mr immortal is a guy
named craig hollis but what's the deal
behind this guy and what are they gonna
do with them in the marvel cinematic
universe well for the quick and dirty
origin here craig hollis is quite
literally a guy who can't die and in
truth it's really more of a healing
factor as well as kind of death and
resurrection to a degree kind of
depending on who's telling the story but
the important thing is he can't dot so
let's refer to the comics here for a
second so in marvel comics when you die
you go to different places depending on
what you did during your life so if you
made a bargain with mephisto for example
you go to his realm when you die but if
you're just anybody who was walking down
the street and just kind of lived a
regular life and you were hit by a car
and died you go to the realm of mistress
death but how do you get there okay so
in marvel comics there's a being called
the death urge and the death urge is by
all standards of measurement what you or
i would refer to as the grim reaper the
person that appears and whisks you away
to whatever afterlife you're supposed to
be going to in this instance when it
came to craig hollis his mother died
during childbirth and that's when he was
first introduced to the concept of death
as well as the death urge because the
death urge ended up taking his mother
away now in the early days of his
stories we didn't really know what the
relationship was between death urge and
crick we didn't know if death urge was
keeping craig safe from death or if
craig was simply unable to die and the
death urge was putting him in
circumstances trying to kill him to take
him to the realm of death or wherever it
is that he was supposed to go we know
this because over the course of the time
that they spent together death urge
would do things like have craig play
patty cake in the middle of the street
with oncoming traffic as like a toddler
or he would have them sit in a tree
during a lightning storm different
things along those lines right but what
ended up happening is there came a point
when death urge actually had craig
playing with matches in the basement of
his house and that it really would have
led to the death of pretty much anybody
under that circumstance and while it did
kill craig's father craig himself
survived and so craig's father was
whisked away by the death urge and then
craig himself was taken to a foster home
now one of those things that happened
there is the death urge kind of lingered
around there and it looked like one of
those circumstances where because craig
was just constantly abused by his father
that death urge was potentially
manipulating that we're not entirely
sure but during this time craig fell in
love with a girl named terry and the two
of them basically ended up going off
into the world and doing their own thing
but there came a point when terry just
couldn't handle it anymore because of
all the experiences she'd had over the
course of her life the abuse of the
hands of her father and so on and so
forth she had what seemed to basically
be ptsd left a suicide note for craig
and took her own life the belief of
craig is that the death urge goaded her
into doing it so craig basically told
death third i don't want to have
anything to do with you anymore go away
and effectively cast him off so any
belief that we had that death urge was
keeping craig safe from death was
immediately eliminated because following
the death of terry and the absence of
death urge that craig kept trying to
take his own life he blew himself up
with tnt he tried to drown himself this
guy quite literally even went so far as
to jump off of a building and just
splatter on the ground below but he
ended up just standing up and basically
healing and that was essentially it but
the important thing here is under no
circumstance can he die in fact even in
the newer immortal folk stories he's the
last surviving thing in the universe
right like literally everything else is
dead planets stars cosmic entities
sentient life the whole nine yards he's
just the last thing there which is
really kind of a wild situation but the
other question to ask is with that being
the case what are they gonna do with him
in the marvel cinematic universe well as
i see it there's really only two options
the first one is he's just a simple
cameo in this episode of she-hulk and we
never see or hear from him again which
is the most likely circumstance the
second possibility is they put him on
the great lakes avengers so for those
guys who don't know in marvel comics you
got all kinds of avengers teams you have
the original avengers team and then the
original avengers team launched the west
coast division so you had avengers west
coast the original avengers team and the
west coast avengers eventually disbanded
and then we got the new avengers then we
got the mighty avengers and then we got
the young avengers and so on and so
forth you had all kinds of teams out
there the great lakes avengers they were
like the cast offs if you could take
everything that makes deadpool comedic
right being goofy and silly and his
stories being just nonsensical and you
could take that concept and turn it into
a comic book superhero team it'd be the
great lakes avengers they're basically
cast offs right like people out there
who are watching this and looking for a
reason to be upset here's one for you
there's a chick on that team named big
bertha who's basically a supermodel that
if she eats a ton of food she gets super
fat and that's where she gets her powers
like enhance durability and strength and
all that kind of stuff so those are you
guys looking to be mad there you go but
the thing about this is that uh when it
comes to that team they're goofy they're
nonsensical there's nothing about them
that you would take serious and when you
look at the character of craig both in
the comics and even in the show they're
very similar in that way there's huge
age differences in the comics craig's
like 22. in the show it looks like he's
in his late 40s maybe early 50s but the
thing about this and really what's
important here is that neither of them
are serious characters so if they were
going to do something with him in the
marvel cinematic universe they would
likely roll him on to the great lakes
avengers team as was probably a comedic
tv show again i don't know if they're
going to do that i stick by the idea
this guy's a one-off cameo we're never
really going to see anything with him
again but there you go that should give
you guys a good understanding of who mr
immortal is he's quite literally a guy
that just can't die but with that being
said we're going to bring this video to
an end thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace peace peace
peace